we've now seen all the artistic elements
that go into making a movie but there's
one person we haven't honored yet
the director for those of you at home
there the CEO the head honcho the grand
pooh-bah the big cheese on set they can
be your mother your father even your
therapist they can even manage hostage
negotiations when a certain actor is
having trouble coming out of their
trailer not that I'm speaking about
myself but you know who you are Ben
Stiller the nominees for Best directing
are Danny Boyle for Slumdog Millionaire
david fincher with a curious case of
benjamin button
for the reader
Danny Boyle
my kids are too old to remember this no
but when they were much younger I swore
to them if this miracle ever happened
that I would receive it in the spirit of
Tigger from Winnie the Pooh and that's
what that was
you have been so generous to us this
evening and I wanted to thank you for
that and also for an extraordinary what
a beautiful show you've done I don't
know what it looks like on television
everybody but in the room it's bloody
wonderful really so well done ok just so
my grace Gabriel and Kaitlyn my kids and
their wonderful mom Gail thank you so
much for letting me be Tigger for so
long and to my dad Frank and to my
sisters Maria and Bernadette and
everybody in st. Mary's social club and
Radcliffe big big big shout out to you
I've got to thank Tessa Ross I've got to
thank everybody at selador I've got to
like Francois and Cameron at cafe I've
got to thank everybody at Warner
Brothers for having the great grace to
pass the film on to the extraordinary
guy at Fox Searchlight Peter rice and
all his team thank you so much Peter
whatever you are thank you so much for
bringing all our cast and crew here or
as many of them as we could do the film
is an absolute tribute to them there's
one guy I should mention we've mentioned
a lot of people I forgot a guy the guy
who choreographed the dance at the end
of the film
he's called Longinus and I forgot him
off the credits and I only found out
about it two weeks ago I'm an idiot and
I apologize from the bottom of my heart
long genus thank you so much
finally just to say to Mumbai unending
inseparable unborn all of you who helps
us make the film and although all of you
those of you who didn't thank you so
much and you dwarf even this guy thank
you very much indeed